you look
beautiful with the tan fishnet it's I'm
loving the whole vibe that's my wolf HS
anyway congratulations baby daughter now
and and your son's
only your your son is only 10 months
he's 10 months old you got two little
ones are you
sleeping a little bit I was going to say
probably not like as soon as one CMS
down the other one they're both so calm
though both of them they don't cry
they're always happy they're so so cute
together little tip don't tell other
mothers this very lucky yeah that's
awesome that's incredible so um her name
is London right yes it's adorable
because your name is Paris that's
amazing did you always have this plan
I've been planning this name forever my
whole life I always knew I wanted a
daughter named London are you serious
yes I didn't even know I wanted
kids that's what you had like you were
one of those girls that like mapped it
out or one of those people that's
awesome yes I just kind of wing it yeah
I just hope it but you're married as
well so the last time oh my God
good I want one of those I was like
that's really beautiful oh my gosh but
you got married since the last time here
you're super happy now I'm so happy he's
just my everything he's so kind and
loyal and sweet and funny and my best
friend and my everything thank you yeah
you look beautiful that's awesome to
find like a friend yes yeah that's good
cuz I think that's what's most important
just finding someone that you can just
spend the rest of your life with and
someone who supports and lifts you up
and I've never had any man be like this
with me oh my gosh I'm so happy for you
and you have a little family now too oh
my God it's incredible you're living
your best life I like it sliving oh
you're sliving I remember that last time
no but I I love how open you are you
have a new Memoir out and I love how
open you are because I've had several
friends that had a really hard time
getting pregnant and you you discussed
that your road to Motherhood was not
easy yes doing IVF which is just
extremely difficult and hard on your
body yes mhm like emot and physically
yes it is yeah but I'm just so grateful
to have my little ones now yeah and it's
amazing too to find like a surrogate
that you trust with that job that would
be my thing I think I'm a tad bit
controlling be like what are you eating
like what are what are you doing like
why I think that which is so stupid
because I ate whatever when I was so I
think I'm harder on others um but does
it feel different now because I I
realized we both were like okay we're
going to be in the spotlight and we
chose that does it feel different though
CU I'm very guarded with my little ones
like of what I will put out there and
won't are you like
that I am um besides on the show because
on Paris and love we show everything
from the moment he was at the hospital
and just going through everything so I'm
excited to show this next phase of my
life yeah I did love that you clap back
though at somebody online because people
I'm like what is wrong with you like
they will say stuff about that's
honestly I just had this talk with my
daughter who's nine now but I was like
no no social media for you like you
don't understand understand the other
side of it she sees the gliter you know
the glittery like fun side of it but
people get really mean and I have
clapped back on people and I love that
you did that because people need to be
reminded like what it is to be human and
that is straight up evil like things
they say about people sometimes
especially kids it's just it really is
just disheartening to know that there's
people out there like that like say what
you want about me but this is my little
baby and for anyone to talk negative
about a child like what's wrong with
there's something wrong with them yeah
that's bear just like my mom yeah no I
am I am as well I think you become that
like you become just vicious like for
them like yeah that's why she's not
allowed online um so you just came out
with a single I didn't realize by the
way that you've been into music so long
I know that you had music out like years
ago but I just mean like since you were
young you've always been singing I don't
think I realized that or many people did
but you have is it lighter is that the
single right now my new single yes
lighter with Steve ioki that's amazing
and I love it and you work with CIA
cia's executive prod producing my whole
album that's incredible I have C I've
done a couple of her songs she's so
gifted so gifted like how she thinks and
like all the different vocal things like
Arrangement wise she does she's
incredible I love her so much she's just
looking forward to this yeah
congratulations that's so
cool
you're
joking oh my God your grandson Phoenix
Baron Helton re are you serious
yeah Paris are you
serious oh my
God oh my
God oh my God are you serious
yeah what is you baby oh my
goodness oh my God this is your
grandma
Kiki oh my gosh we're back with parison
that was the look at her Show Paris and
love season two starts tomorrow on
peock that was that real she had no idea
no idea oh my God what a beautiful thing
to have like for the rest of her life
that moment it was quite the surprise
yeah explain the show this season though
is there a lot of that going on surpris
well season two is just all about this
next stage in my life being a mom and a
wife and just everything that comes with
motherhood and balancing it all with you
know being a working mom hard yeah a
sliving mom is what I call myself
exactly um but how did your family react
to like the Memoir cuz I I don't know I
think I that's why I haven't written one
um they were it was very emotional just
because I wrote about things that I've
never told anyone not my closest friends
my family so it was just very shocking
for them to read um but it's brought us
so much closer but it was definitely
really difficult just because I was so
open in that book a big message of my
book is to not be ashamed of things when
the shame shouldn't be on you it should
be on the people that hurt you
absolutely but that would has been hard
like finding out from your family yes
yeah very
I don't yeah my mom would not handle she
didn't handle because of you well so a
memoir would kill
her I was like my bad um wait so it's 20
years since um a simple life that's
crazy 20 year anniversary is coming up
20 year anniversary what do you remember
from that you and Nicole yeah yes look
at your little baby your little baby
thank you Nicole and I just the most
amazing memories we're actually at my
house like last month watching some
episodes together and just is that hard
do you watch like this no we love it I
just laugh so hard that show is just so
hilarious it so much fun I think that my
favorite was the Walmart episode yes I
was like oh my God I grew up in a
Walmart we're so
different I am the people of Walmart I
know uh you know that thing you see
online like totally me I know I love how
I said what's Walmart do they sell Walls
there and now we're selling Paris Hilton
cookware I know well you know what it is
it's a great it's hard to get your stuff
in Walmart people don't realize that
it's hard to get your stuff in like
Walmart or Target like those are like
places those are hard places to get like
your St to so killing it selling out
everywhere so it's amazing I love it
awesome well so you recently posted this
um old picture and this was you and
Britney y'all were young um so younger I
should say but Britney actually just
released a memoir as well and she said
something really cool so I'm going to
tell everybody so it says one of the
people who was kindest to me when I
really needed kindness was Paris Hilton
like that's you know I don't feel like
good news gets spread often it's always
like this person did this to me this
person it's always bad I thought it was
really cool to like read something kind
about someone and like lift that up did
you feel good about that yeah I was
crying when I read that I thought that
was just that really touched me she's
just so strong I love her so much and
I'm just so proud of her for speaking
her truth and writing this whole book
and yeah that quote just meant a lot to
me when I read it yeah and you both were
very young in this industry and like
growing up that can't be easy so you
know how it is yeah I I feel like there
has to be purpose in things that happen
to us the good and the bad and I love
that you're a really big advocate for
like trouble teen industry like anything
going on in that area because you had
struggled that's really cool so that's
important to you to keep up yes I'm just
so proud of all the impact that I've
made with telling my story I've now
changed laws in 10 states and going back
and forth to Washington DC and we're
pushing for federal legislation and
we've made it bipartisan we have both
sides that are supporting this so
congratulations that never happens yeah
really proud that's really cool like cuz
I think that people look at you like
from afar and maybe don't know like your
life now they will with a memoir but
like I don't think they know that and so
it's kind of cool for people that are
struggling to go okay I can do this like
she did this I think that's really
important you yeah and changing laws
you're doing everything okay let's take
another break everybody season two of
Paris and love premieres tomorrow on
[Music]
peacock
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home